you're saying possibly this is not ready
to pitch to investors because we don't
have a lot of things determined but how
can we make this idea better
the internal butler
well it's really about you know we're
looking for
so we started with a character
and we're looking for is this character
truly unique is this character a
character conceit yeah
um a character we've never seen before
on screen this is a story we've never
seen before on screen yet so if you keep
asking yourself that question
then i would say no
you know i've seen some versions of this
i'm i'm still seeing the movie that i've
seen
not the movie that we're developing it's
still not its own
path it's something that i'm pouring out
a world for but it's not its own unique
conceit it's not its own original thing
ultimately
and so until you see that i think
especially when you're dealing with
you know we haven't even written like a
one sentence like a one-liner that says
okay this is who what when where and why
like this is what's happening um we're
kind of taking these little
random pieces and we've pulled it
together
and
gotten something that is going in a
direction but it certainly still could
go in so many different directions that
it's it's early development and that's
what's great about early development
is that you
at this point in stage
anybody could get to this point
so i think that one of the things like i
was saying it's like when an idea when
you're developing an idea it's like you
have to get beyond your first
idea of that idea
anyone can come up with the first idea
it's getting beyond that first layer of
it and getting to your next id and your
next idea beyond that so that and that's
even with scenes
like making a scene not just resting on
the first premise or first idea that you
come up with for a scene but actually
pushing it beyond what that coming up
with more ideas for that scene
coming up more ideas for how that story
can work that's how you test and how you
push your story development rather than
just stumbling upon
what you know
or what is coming off the top of your
head which
is pretty much the same for anybody else
and therefore will be mundane
and will not be original
do we know the stakes that this
character will have to overcome
well i think that though sometimes
they'll be
you know life and death in the sense of
his existence as a butler but will they
be truly life and death i don't know i
mean there's an emotional life and death
that you can face you know so he'll face
one already when he discovers a secret
and if he does have to
stand up and you know go like mad max
and protect the whole village of people
we never know so you know he could
we haven't figured out where he's
wondering the earth too yet
um he could be lord of flies in it so
i mean he could go any direction
but that would give you the opportunity
to give him stakes you know maybe just
like we were talking about like him
being the superhero almost type of
sidekick well it's like that now the
youngest son had to go to war and he
went with him i mean he could be all
kinds of stuff and protecting him like i
mean i could come up with all kinds of
life or life or death types of things
but i think as long as it's a
spiritual life or death it will have
that kind of stakes going on
and i think that's important especially
for indie dramas
um that there's a kind of that arc of
like you know there's a rebirth or death
or phoenix or real life type of thing
right because let's suppose he had only
dead he had suppressed so much about
himself and it was all in service to
this family and making sure they were
seeing maybe they were a very public
wealthy family and he wanted to make
sure they were only seen right in the
right light
and now he finds out this secret and
everything
crumbles he doesn't care anymore maybe
and now it's about his journey so maybe
he shut that off i don't know i'm just
no absolutely that's and i think that's
what we talked about from the beginning
it's really about what that what that
how far does that wondering go because
he could just go one like he can just go
wandering out into the desert you know
he could go wander out into the palm
desert and go live in a hotel with a
bunch of like like a whole bunch of
weirdos
do what i mean like there's one like in
a mat like he goes and he goes and stays
in hotel
uh in the middle of palm springs some
abandon or a middle of palmdale that
used to be whatever and now it's like a
it's really like a it's more of a
pay-by-week hotel you know hotel so
there's a family in there doing mexican
family maybe and a black family and
there's you know the the crazy old drag
queen maybe and then there's you know
and you just have this collection of
people and in some level his
you know him having lost himself and
those people bringing him back to life
if he wanders into that place
now that's actually becoming an
interesting movie
uh and that's why
you continue to
push your boundaries of what an actual
movie can be
because the more that you push and allow
your imagination to wonder if that's
really what it is
and i think that's really what a movie
is
a movie is pushing it to something that
you want to go see it in a theater and
things that if it's not going to have
the scope that we're talking about it
has to have the emotional scope
that we're talking about where it's
going to rip you into a new person
uh you know and and change your view of
a world and give you maybe an insight
that you never had uh and then maybe in
a view that you didn't have through eyes
that you didn't have that's why peter
dinklage is such a unique you know what
if the butler is peter dinklage
you know what you know what you know so
there's so many whatevs what if that
character is half black
yeah and and then they're you know there
could be so many other things that are
involved in these layers that you start
to when you have an independent mind for
casting an independent mind for the
movie
you know rather than i'm going to make
this a studio movie because the first
thing i think is i'm going to not make
it a studio
i'm going to i want to be how am i going
to make this movie is the first thing i
think so then i think well how am i
going to do that
sure and and when you talk about an
abandoned hotel in palmdale i'm sure
there's some for for rent and that'd be
great because maybe it's a hotel of what
seems like transients but it's really
people that lost their identities maybe
this old drag queen they used to perform
and they were really something back in
the day
and it was this private club that no one
wanted to be seen at but everybody
wanted to be there kind of thing and
then this person was no longer a hot
performer because they got older
and then maybe somebody so it was all
it's all these people that lost their
identities and in a sense became a
family
maybe dysfunctional whatever but i like
it yeah and has it then it's just then
it's just dropping this this random
other rando character into this world
now that that really doesn't fit into
that world at all
um since but it completely does
because it's completely lost
right now how this butler would get to
this hotel because this seems like this
would not be something in their
wheelhouse to ever flow i think it's
like it becomes like that the the almost
like the wandering in the desert until i
came upon something
you know if i use a great if i'm getting
really artsy at that moment that he goes
into this we wondered you know he
literally just wonders he just strips
off his clothes literally and wanders
out into the desert and and that's where
he's the first place he is found
you know that maybe the mexican family
that's going you know to kind of trying
to find a place too they they they haul
them along
you know on the thing and then they
rescue them and they bring them to this
place and then now they're there
you know i mean it's it you know i've
seen
much less believable circumstances so
i mean it's a movie
right right
and
have we determined the this arc
that this butler will have i mean it
sounds
like they kind of lost they thought they
knew who they were they lost themselves
and then in the end have they found
themselves well i think they will
through like like
by changing their preconceived notions
about
who they are and what the world is
um by looking at a completely different
way and having to look at things
differently i think that that will
you know but i'm not i'm not into the
necessary the very clean
you know
tidy
i don't like that tidy telling you stuff
i like some of that to just be like you
know it'll end somewhere and you're
gonna have to decide you'll have to
think about it yourself
um as an individual where that person
will end
you know i like those by the way because
i think it gets like a good book you
know it's like it gives you that thing
but it gives you something to think
about
um and you for you to decide